hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
einen richtig leckeren käse kuchen und
die zubereitung dauert keine zehn
minuten
für den boden benutze ich löffelbiskuits
und butterkekse und die quarkmasse
verfeinert mit vanille extrakt und
zitronensaft jetzt zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zubereitung für den
boden
wir benötigen butterkekse außerdem noch
löffelbiskuits und geschmolzene butter
und für den kranz gebe ich dann noch
gehobelte mandeln dazu die habe ich
bereit in der pfanne gerüstet nun werden
zuallererst die löffelbiskuits und auch
die butterkekse fein gemahlen
ich nehme dafür immer ganz gerne meinen
mixa wer einen solchen aber nicht da hat
der kann selbstverständlich auch die
kekse in einen beutel tun und dann mit
einem nudelholz da drauf hauen bis sie
komplett zerkleinert sind
wer mag kann statt der butterkekse auch
vollkorn butterkeksen nehmen das
schmeckt auch sehr lecker komplett
löffelbiskuits würde ich aber nicht
nehmen für den boden da der sonst zu süß
wird sobald ihr die kekse alle komplett
zerkleinert habt gebt ihr die flüssige
butter mit hinzu und verrührt das
gründlich miteinander
die gehobelten und gerösteten mandeln
gebe ich aber an der stelle nicht mit
dazu denn die kommen am ende oben drauf
damit wir den besonderen crunch haben
jetzt gebe ich den keks boden auf meinen
mit backpapier ausgelegte springform die
hat eine größe von 26 zentimetern und
die kekse drücke ich jetzt noch mit
einem flachen glas an
und sobald auch dieser schritt erledigt
ist geben wir die gehobelte mandeln
schließlich auf dem boden
das sorgt noch mal für den extra quatsch
wenn ihr in den kuchen reinbeißen und
schon geht es weiter mit unserer füllung
hierfür benötigen wir magerquark
weichweizen griesmayr sowie geschmolzene
butter den saft einer halben zitrone
außerdem vanille extrakt ihr könnt aber
stattdessen auf vanillezucker nehmen
backpulver und weißem zucker die
zubereitung ist so einfach wir
vermischen jetzt alle zutaten
miteinander
ich gehe da gerne sofort dass ich
zuallererst die flüssige butter mit dem
zucker verrühren und anschließend die
eier dazugeben
sobald die eier dann gut untergerührt
wurden geben wir den weizen grease mit
hinzu und schließlich auch den quark
nun kommt noch das backpulver mit hinzu
und wird gut untergerührt
für den feinen geschmack gebe ich jetzt
noch den saft einer halben zitrone mit
dazu und schließlich auch das von extras
nun wird das ganze noch mal gut durch
gehört und dann ist unsere füllung auch
schon fertig
die gebe ich jetzt auf meinen
tortenboden verstreicht ihr das noch
einmal ganz kurz glatt und dann kommt
sie in den ofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für ca 45 minuten
nach der backzeit empfehle ich euch
definitiv den kuchen im backofen
auskühlen zu lassen
dafür schaltet ihr den ofen komplett aus
und klemmt ein holzlöffel zwischen die
ofentür so dass die heiße luft
entweichen kann und anschließend sollte
der kuchen noch mal im kühlschrank
komplett durch kühlen
der käse kuchen schmeckt unglaublich
lecker und man glaubt gar nicht dass er
so schnell geht probiert ihn unbedingt
aus und teilt mir euer feedback in den
kommentaren mit
außerdem freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen
kanal abonniert damit ihr auch keines
meiner videos mehr verpasst bis zum
nächsten mal auf welches kitchen